hello ladies and gentlemen today we're
talking about jay mazzini he's in the
late stage of a scam guys
listen scammer life cycles go through a
lot of things there's the
initial up before anyone's heard of them
and they start getting some traction
selling the dream then there's the peak
of their popularity but inevitably
the reviews start coming in people start
telling their story the scam pages come
out and they slowly dive down into
obscurity that can happen a lot of
different ways it can happen like a
whimper
or they can go out with a bang and i'm
convinced that jay mazzini
is trying to do the latter he's not he's
not content to go out into obscurity
like many other uh scammers have in the
past
he wants to go out like as cynically as
possible
ripping off his fan base now let's be
clear let's catch you up i made a video
about the 100 million dollar scam
where he talked about jay mazzini's
clothing line mazzini italy where he was
promising giveaways that of course never
happened he had promised like ten
thousand dollars
if you bought like a hundred dollars
worth of product on his website i mean
crazy things like that to the point
where
he had literally promised to 100 million
dollars in giveaways hear this
quickly for the next 200 people
to place in thousand mazzini italy
orders like
for each person to place in one a
thousand dollar mazzini italy order
it's a lot but i'll be cutting out
a check for 125 000 now recently what
has he been
doing well he's been doing a bitcoin
scam
now normally we see this with surprising
is normally we see this with the uh
with actual hackers like you're hacked
and then you start posting about bitcoin
with jay mazzini
i don't see any evidence that he was
hacked instead this almost looks like
something he would just
normally do so he started posting on his
twitter account
i am buying bitcoin a little above
market price i am buying bitcoin and you
know
several times he's been posting this
since january 1. he says he's paying
5.5 over market value for bitcoin
and why is he doing that why is he not
just buying it on an exchange so you can
just see he keeps posting about it
it's because he says he has an account
limit and he just wants to buy
so much bitcoin he wants to buy it at
its peak guys i messaged him actually i
got some hit me up
he never did surprisingly now what's
interesting to note here is that even
though
he keeps posting about this he also is
deleting it constantly on his
instagram so as you can see there's no
giveaway here
although once again if you go back to
his twitter all the j mazzini
uh bitcoin scams are still up and
running as usual so how does this game
work now that we know sort of what he's
doing his social media is dying because
people have exposed him as a scam
and now he's you know he's taking
people's bitcoin well here's how it
works muhammad amar went through this
and not only that he took screenshots
so jay mazzini starts it and he'll tell
you i'm just sitting for two coins now
you're gonna be good
i really don't want to be in an awkward
position this guy says i got you brother
i need 20 minutes to send hey brother
it's sent
so sends a wire transfer okay
inshallah man i will be on the lookout
by the way this is what you call
i mean it's not a true affinity scam but
this is this is
kind of falls down that line an affinity
scam is when somebody tries to
uh use your fellow class of maybe
identity
to try to get you to trust them so in uh
in jay mazzini's case it's the fact that
he is a muslim
right and so he's constantly posting
about his faith which
that's fine but then he uses that to try
to bring you in and say he's trustworthy
and then scam you in the end so again
after he sends it the wire transfer
isn't there he supposedly sent
it so he says okay am i getting the
point nine coin inshallah send me your
details we will sort it out blah blah
blah
he doesn't get it uh he says i sent a
wire for 81 000 you should receive it in
two to three business days at the most
classic
scam what's the word you trying to play
me so now he's pretending to get upset
about the fact he hasn't been paid his
bitcoin yet even though he hasn't really
paid his wire
this guy says i text you in the morning
you said you just sent the coin today
are you gonna wait till you get the wire
then send it
this guy says wire has been canceled who
are you for me to send you the funds
first then you send me the coin
sorry i'm not obligated to trust you
first
obviously this is ridiculous jay mazzini
has chosen to go outside
the the broker uh traditional method of
getting bitcoin because he wants to
sort of buy it up but then he wants
people to send him cash first
obviously it is a scam why would you pay
5.5 over market value for this now this
guy correctly
responds neither am i bro you're asking
me to send you 0.9 bitcoin or 35 000
just because you texted me this you
didn't show me any proof either it's
really sad to see this kind of stuff
coming from you bro i always thought
you're a really legit guy with a good
heart but you high-key cheating people
yes that's correct uh yo bro i don't
know you from a hole in the wall to send
you anything first who are you if
anything you're cheating
me you want me to wait for funds to
reach you so i can say oj i'm not gonna
run i'm supposed to trust you first
okay classic manipulation yeah so what
what can we learn from this ladies and
gentlemen well i mean what's the point
of all this
is it just that jay mazzini's pathetic
well that's definitely part of it
you know he does these giveaways where
he he pretends to be giving away money
to people
he lives this lifestyle of having all
this cash right so that's the thing
that's going on with jay mazzini i mean
he's a classic con man they've been
around forever
but they manipulate you by making you
feel like you're the untrustworthy one
for not putting your money with them
right and that's what this guy's doing
he's saying i'm the successful
businessman blah blah blah blah
even though there's no proof of that i
gotta tell you um there's no proof of
anything this guy has done
as a matter of fact except for flash
money around and scam people
so yeah i just wanted to put this out
there do not fall for
for this guy's lies uh and and recently
the
the scam has just gotten so blatant that
i felt an obligation
to tell you guys about this so you can
avoid this man at all costs
he will tell you everything you want to
hear but then you'll be left holding the
bag do not
fall for this stuff guys honestly it's
so funny because every time you see a
bitcoin scam now you just assume they're
hacked
and it's just funny to see someone who
probably is not hacked because this
falls right along with you know the
normal mo of james
so yeah that's basically it just wanted
to get this out real quick tell you guys
what was happening
that's it see yay
[Music]
wake up and smell the coffee you just
want my dollar bills
i got this funny feel that what you made
of who you are is really nothing real
you trying to fleece mine i throw a
peace sign i gotta go cause people like
you i spend the least time
but coffee zilla there's
until there's
you